big data can be characterized by more
than the 3v that we mentioned in the
previous session
those were volume velocity and variety
there are several practical differences
as well
jules berman has a book called
principles of big data
preparing sharing and analyzing complex
information
he lists 10 ways that big data is
different from small data
the first is goals small data is usually
gathered for a specific goal
big data on the other hand may have a
goal in mind when it's first started
but things can evolve or take unexpected
directions
the second is location small data is
usually in one place
and often in a single computer file big
data on the other hand can be in
multiple
files in multiple servers on computers
in different geographic locations
third the data structure and content
small data is usually highly structured
like an excel spreadsheet
and it has rows and columns of data big
data on the other hand can be
unstructured
it can have many formats and files
involved across disciplines
and may link to other resources
fourth data preparation small data is
usually prepared by the end user for
their own purposes
but with big data the data is often
prepared by one group of people
analyzed by a second group of people and
then used by a third group of people
and they may have different purposes and
they may have different disciplines
fifth longevity small data is usually
kept for a specific amount of time after
the project is over because there's a
clear ending point
in the academic world it's maybe five or
seven years and then you can throw it
away
but with big data each data project
because it often comes at a great cost
gets continued into others and so you
have data in perpetuity
and things are going to stay there for a
very long time
they may be added on to in terms of new
data at the front
or contextual data of things that
occurred beforehand
or additional variables or linking up
with different files
so it has a much longer and really
uncertain lifespan compared to a small
data set
the sixth is measurements small data is
typically measured with a single
protocol
using set units and it's usually done at
the same time
with big data on the other hand because
you can have people in very different
places
in very different times different
organizations and countries
you may be measuring things using
different protocols and you may have to
do a fair amount of conversion to get
things consistent
number seven is reproducibility small
data sets can usually be reproduced in
their entirety
if something goes wrong in the process
big data sets on the other hand
because they come in so many forms and
from different directions
it may not be possible to start over
again if something's gone wrong
usually the best you can hope to do is
to at least identify which parts of the
data project are problematic
and keep those in mind as you work
around them
number eight is stakes on small data
if things go wrong the costs are limited
it's not an enormous problem but with
big data
projects can cost hundreds of millions
of dollars and losing the data
or corrupting the data can doom the
project possibly even the researchers
career or the organization's existence
the ninth is what's called introspection
and what this means
is that the data describes itself in an
important way
with small data the ideal for instance
is what's called a triple that's used in
several programming languages where you
say
first off the object that is being
measured
in a small data set things tend to be
well organized
individual data points can be identified
and it's usually clear what things mean
in a big data set however because things
can be so complex with many files
and many formats you may end up with
information that is unidentifiable
unlocatable or meaningless the final
characteristic is analysis
with small data it's usually possible to
analyze all of the data at once in a
single procedure from a single computer
file
with big data however because things are
so enormous and they're spread across
lots of different files and servers
you may have to go through extraction
reviewing reduction
normalization transformation and other
steps and deal with one part of the data
at a time to make it more manageable
and then eventually aggregate your
results
so it becomes clear from this that
there's more than just volume and
velocity
and variety there are a number of
practical issues that can make things
more complex with big data than with
small data
you